>>Aaron: When a lot of people
think about flipped classrooms,
they start thinking about
videos, lots and lots of videos.
Video, video, video,
video, video.
And video has a technological
component to it,
and a lot of people then think
that the flipped classroom
is a technological solution.
Well, we think a flipped
classroom is a pedagogical
solution with a technological
component,
a very large technological
component, so let's get some
of these tech tools on the table
so we can get you the tools
that you need to start
flipping your class.
>>Jon: But Aaron why do I
need to make my own videos?
There's lots of videos
out there.
Two plus two equals four,
whether I say it or somebody
on the internet says it.
>>Aaron: Well, you're right,
there's plenty of material
out there but I think it's
really best for teachers to try
at least to make
their own content.
There's a relational aspect
that you have with your students
that no one else in this world
has, and you cannot replace
that by using someone
else's material.
So I've decided to make
my own video content.
I don't know the first
thing about making videos,
what do I need to
make this happen?
>>Jon: I know a teacher, he
hands the phone to a student
and says, "Can you help me
make a video after class?"
And they shoot the video of
him standing at the chalkboard
and then he posts
the video online.
>>Aaron: And if you choose
a student who's struggling,
that student is going
to get it twice.
They're going to see you when
they're there live with you
and then they can go back and
view that video content again.
>>Both: Differentiated
instruction.
>>Jon: Another tool for making
flipped class videos are screen
casting programs.
Whatever is on the
screen is recorded.
>>Aaron: And in case you haven't
noticed, tablets are everywhere,
and there are a plethora of
whiteboarding apps for tablets
that you can write on the
screen, bring in pictures,
record your audio to produce
video content for your students.
Okay, so now that you've
created some video content,
where are you going to put it
so your students can access it?
>>Jon: There's a plethora
of sites such as YouTube
and Vimeo you can use, but what
if your kids don't have access?
A lot of kids, well,
they don't have access
to the technology,
what do you do then?
>>Aaron: We have physical
media that we could use.
We have USB drives, they're
relatively inexpensive.
Get a few of those, check them
out to your students as needed,
or you could burn
them onto a DVD.
>>Jon: So with all these
tools for creation and sharing
of the videos, we're often
asked, which is the best tool
or tools that you should use?
Ultimately, it depends upon you.
What technology are
you comfortable with,
what do you actually have?
That's the tool that's
going to be best for you.